字幕志愿者 杨茜茜
歡迎各位現場的朋友們
今天莉玲參加
由原副證券所主辦的巨人節
我是焦藝園財經座談會
接下來就借由大家熱烈的掌聲
我們一同來歡迎今天的主獎人
巨人節
這些心態或是觀念或邏輯
看起來或許只是一個簡單的道理
但背後是我用15年來的交易歲月
以及破照遠的成交量
換來的深刻體會
你跟搭戶的距離其實只有經驗跟邏輯
以及有沒有辦法利用這些經驗跟邏輯
轉換成交易策略
所以你原本覺得跟大戶的距離是有什麼
爵士武功 武功秘技 葵花寶典
其實只是想像力 觀察跟經驗上的差異而已
其實賺錢的方法你們都是知道的
只是沒有花時間去看它而已
盡量講著淺寫一懂
跟舉一些比較簡單的例子
希望大家有些收穫 謝謝大家
我們今天的第一個驚喜海蛋
掌聲歡迎Nick 周湯好
再一次講聲謝謝Nake
接下來我們一起歡迎
巨人節以及Joman
試單的時候賠的時候
你也是很快就會撤場
很快就停水
我一秒進去我下一秒不對
或是我滑鼠點下去那一瞬間我覺得不對
下一秒我就再點一下就直接停水
只要是停水一定是對的
檢討絕對是沒有一個對跟錯的這件事情
其實我可以放大的關鍵是因為我的風暴筆是很嚴苛的
好 我賠錢看錯 賠1% 但是我只有一張
賺錢我看對 我是100張乘上2%
所以你的風暴筆就起來了
所以4月對你來說反而你有達到一個算不錯的買點
解決了心理壓力 解決了槓桿壓力
解決了資金壓力
你就可以冷靜地去做行情的判斷
我自己還有我見過很多真正成功的大物
他們有一個共通點
他們熱愛交易
他們享受研究
享受市場帶來的刺激與成長
那不是壓力
那是一種快樂
交易對我來說
就是一個一輩子學習的旅程
优优独播剧场——YoYo Television Series Exclusive